In early October, one of Haiti’s largest
companies made a startling announcement:
due to insufficient supplies, it
could no longer produce water.
Without clean water, the country soon
became victim to an outbreak of cholera.
And although the disease is both
preventable and treatable, Haiti’s capital,
Port-au-Prince — population: nearly one million
— was down to just three working ambulances.
…Yet neither a lack of clean water,
a deadly outbreak of cholera,
nor even an acute shortage of medical care top
the list of Haiti’s most pressing challenges.
These are merely three symptoms
of a much bigger problem:
a chronic fuel shortage — causing
prices to climb as high as $50 a gallon.
Without fuel, ambulances couldn’t respond to
emergencies, children couldn’t get to school,
and electricity was unavailable even
to homes fortunate enough to have it.
Many companies couldn’t even pay their workers
— effectively pressing ‘pause’ on civilization.
The fuel shortage was caused by
the blockade of a storage site
responsible for 70% of the nation’s
oil by an armed coalition of gangs.
The same gangs who regularly terrorize
the population — carrying out violence
in broad daylight, often in view of police.
Unfortunately, this is nothing new.
In Haiti, it’s often difficult to discern
where one crisis ends and another begins.
Articles from years past could almost
be reprinted word-for-word today.
This one from 2019 perfectly
describes the most recent crisis.
And these two — written over a
decade apart — sound eerily similar.
Stories of one or another disaster in Haiti
have become an almost routine feature of
the news cycle — along with North Korean
missile tests and Facebook privacy scandals.
Just last year it was hit with
a magnitude 7.2 earthquake,
killing thousands and doing 10% of
the entire national GDP in damage.
Haiti’s president was
assassinated just 38 days earlier.
And only 67 miles away from this most recent
earthquake was the epicenter of another in 2010.
That one killed at least 160,000 people and
destroyed some of its most historic buildings.
The result has been decades
of economic stagnation.
This is the average GDP in the Latin America
and Caribbean region — its neighbors.
These are all low-income countries.
And this, meanwhile, is Haiti.
40% of the population — 4.4 million people
— need urgent humanitarian assistance.
Now, there’s no doubt geography plays a role.
The island sits in an earthquake hotspot within
a hotspot and hurricanes are a fact of life.
The data is unambiguous: natural
disasters occur more frequently,
do more damage, and are more fatal
in Haiti, compared to its neighbors.
But what all these things have in common — from
its inability to recover from natural disasters
to the fact that gangs can effectively hijack
the entire country — is a lack of state capacity.
The government is weak, overwhelmed,
and, frequently, short-lived.
In the three and a half decades
between 1986 and 2021, for instance,
the average president served
for just 1 year and 11 months.
In that time, only two served their
full five-year terms. One lasted just
3 days. And 7 of these 19 presidents
held office for less than a year.
Political instability is — by far — the
country’s number 1 barrier to development.
The question is: if political instability is the
root of Haiti’s problems, what’s
the root of this instability?
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula. For a
limited time, right now for the holidays, you
can get both for an amazing $11.59/year and start
watching my exclusive series “China, Actually”.
When the thirteen colonies declared independence
in 1776, the United States was overshadowed,
economically, by one of its
tiny Southern neighbors… Haiti.
Then a French colony, Haiti was the source of
75% of the world’s sugar and half of its coffee,
despite being roughly the size of Massachusetts.
It was, in fact, the richest colony in the New
World, though, of course, this immense wealth
did not reach the almost million slaves who,
at one point or another, were brought there.
But what their French colonizers didn’t
realize is that many of these slaves
were former soldiers, captured in
battle throughout central Africa.
And when the French Revolution reached
the shores of Haiti in 1791, they rose up,
declaring the first independent Caribbean
state and first free black republic.
To symbolize this, the republic’s first flag was
based on France’s, with the white stripe removed.
There was, however, one major problem.
A bit of “small print” that would haunt
the country for centuries to come.
Although Haiti had triumphed in battle
against the French, Spanish, English,
and even Napoleon himself, there was
one thing it still needed: recognition.
For France, losing control of its most
profitable colony was a national embarrassment.
For years it refused even to speak the name
“Haiti”, pretending as if nothing ever happened.
But without recognition, Haiti was effectively
stuck in limbo — unable to sign treaties,
send diplomats, or feel secure in its sovereignty.
So, having exhausted all other options,
Haiti’s president made a suggestion:
What if it could simply pay?
For years, the two countries negotiated back
and forth until one day France decided enough
was enough. Haiti would owe it 112 million
Francs — about 560 million in today’s dollars,
French goods would be subject to
only half the standard tariffs,
and, in return, it would finally
recognize the country’s existence.
But this time it wasn’t asking. If Haiti refused,
it threatened to bombard the
capital with cannon fire.
Haiti had no choice.
While many empires have been
called on to pay reparations,
only in Haiti did slaves pay their former masters
— forced, essentially, to buy their own bodies.
France didn’t just steal much-needed
resources from this newly independent
republic — resources it used to build the Eiffel
Tower — it also trapped the country
in a payday loan-like cycle of debt.
It had no choice but to
take on more and more loans,
often with predatory interest rates and fees.
In 1838, half of Haiti’s annual budget
was spent on the military. Less than 1%
on education. And about 30%
servicing its national debt.
By the turn of the century, that 30% had
become 50. And in 1914, a staggering 80%.
It’s been estimated that without this debt,
the nation’s per capita income
might be six times higher today!
…And yet even this steep sacrifice did not
earn Haiti a seat at the international table.
More than fifty years after it declared
independence, two important powers still
refused to recognize it: the
Vatican and the United States.
To do so, places like America and Britain thought,
might inspire similar
revolts among slaves at home.
Only in 1862, after Southern states left the
Union, did the U.S. officially recognize it.
Little did Haiti know, American involvement would
soon become much more a curse than a blessing.
Between 1870 and 1905, the share of
U.S. imports to Haiti nearly doubled,
from less than 40% to over 70.
The former French colony effectively
freed itself from the grips of one
empire only to replace it with another.
And this new one was no less greedy.
From Washington’s point of view, Haiti was
becoming far too dominated by German merchants,
who weren’t afraid to use their
wealth to support revolution.
On the eve of World War I, Americans weren’t too
keen on inviting the Germans into their backyard.
They also had an interest in
opening up Haiti’s economy,
which, as a safeguard against a return to
slavery, was largely off-limits to foreigners.
In reality, the Germans likely had
no intention of taking over Haiti.
But it didn’t matter — the United States
saw its golden opportunity to kill two
birds with one stone. To drive out the
Germans while converting a perennial
source of instability just 600 miles from
Florida into an obedient client state.
The U.S. government, at the time, didn’t
actually know much about Haiti. But it soon
found an ally more than happy to fill
its vacuum of knowledge: Wall Street.
To American corporations, Haiti represented a
giant untapped market — if only it were stable.
The only thing that could stabilize
it, they decided, was U.S. occupation.
And the only thing that could compel
U.S. occupation was an acute crisis.
So, they set out to create one.
The National City Bank of New York
— now known as Citibank — set its
plan in motion by purchasing a
majority stake in a Haitian bank.
But not just any ordinary bank.
As a private, for-profit French
corporation, it could simply be bought.
But it also just so happened to
serve as Haiti’s national treasury,
with a monopoly on printing
currency, holding tax revenue,
and even commercial lending — services
it provided to the government for a fee.
Whoever owned it, in other
words, effectively owned Haiti.
All the Americans had to do to get what
they wanted was withhold the government’s
money. Or just outright steal it.
And that’s exactly what they did.
Their opportunity came after another investor,
James MacDonald, promised to build a railway
connecting two of Haiti’s largest cities.
In exchange, he was granted the rights to
12 miles of land on each side of the tracks,
where he planned on building banana plantations.
To locals, this sounded suspiciously
like a return to the exact kind of
foreign-owned export economy the
country was founded to prevent.
These alarm bells led to an uprising,
and seven presidents came and went
in a matter of just four years.
Although this was far from the
most violence Haiti had ever seen,
this time American property was “at risk” —
providing the perfect pretext for an invasion.
In 1914, U.S. Marines landed in Port-au-Prince,
stole millions of dollars in gold from the
national treasury, and sailed away as if they
hadn’t just committed 17th-century armed piracy.
A year later, they returned. This time,
they stayed for nearly two decades,
during which the U.S. installed a
puppet government, declared martial law,
and re-established a form of forced labor.
Beating out the French for the
title of Haiti’s biggest villain
was a near-impossible task but
the Americans somehow managed.
Far from stabilizing the country, laying the
groundwork for rapid economic development,
as intended, U.S. involvement
had an unexpected consequence.
Not only did it centralize power and
help normalize political violence,
but it also undermined the
government’s legitimacy.
How could Haitians see their
leaders as being legitimate,
when they answered first to Washington?
Now, to be clear, the Haitian
government has historically
been just as much a perpetrator
as a victim of this broken system.
Corruption is rampant and violence,
at best, tolerated, and all too
often, outright state-sponsored.
Nobody — in or outside of Haiti — trusts
its government. And for good reason.
But this creates its own problems.
Take, for example, the
devastating 2010 earthquake.
Unlike most foreign natural disasters, it not
only captured but sustained the world’s attention.
Millions donated to relief efforts and
$2.29 billion in aid was promised in total.
Suddenly Haiti was being overwhelmed with
money, and, for once, genuine goodwill.
The only question was where to put it.
When the earthquake struck, the
government of Haiti was so weak
that UN peacekeepers were already in
the country on a different mission.
It not only wiped out virtually
every public building but also the
very UN building which would’ve
provided earthquake relief.
Just 1% of humanitarian aid and
23% of recovery funds between
2010 and ‘11 were directed to the government.
Instead, nearly every last penny went,
as it always does in Haiti, to NGOs.
And as more and more money bypasses the
government, it becomes weaker and weaker,
ensuring the next crisis is even deadlier.
It’s clear that Haiti will never
escape this cycle until it has strong,
capable, and competent leadership.
But it’s also become abundantly
clear that foreign intervention
is more likely to aggravate
than relieve Haiti’s suffering.
That, although the source of its challenges
may be foreign, the cure can’t be.
That, although geography may predispose
the country to frequent natural disasters,
the Haiti of 2022 was far from predetermined.
“Natural” explanations for Haiti’s struggles are
simply an excuse for centuries of abuse by
foreign powers. The same storm, after all,
can be catastrophic in one place and
only mildly inconvenient in another.
And the scientific reasons for that
are, actually, quite interesting.
This weekend I’m watching “Countdown to a
Catastrophe: Storms” on today’s sponsor,
CuriosityStream, home to thousands of great
documentaries on history, science, and nature.
Right now, for a limited time during the holidays,
you can get CuriosityStream and Nebula
together 42% off — for just $11.59 a year.
On Nebula, you can watch my exclusive
Original series “China, Actually”,
including the episode I just released
last week explaining why China has a
surprisingly responsible nuclear
posture and why that matters.
At less than a dollar a month for two streaming
platforms, you won’t find a better deal. Click
the link on screen right now to get both Nebula
and CuriosityStream and start watching today.